out of all the videos that were  recording was there any City or any area  that wouldn't give you the recording or  was not somehow someway available to see  yes so a number of areas did not take  video which is actually very bad because  think of it number one we live in a  country and at a time when technology is  cheap uh every Mall every parking lot is  on the video right any is there any good  reason not to put a camera on a Dropbox  how many places was that was a lot of  places that was the necessary places the  majority of places did not have video at  all and they basically used the excuse  of covid they basically said oh you know  yeah we should but we never got around  to it so there are only a few places  that did video and and even those places  fight you when you try to get the video  they don't make it easily available why  not  um so this is right away a clue that  they're trying to block you from  watching what's on the video